自分の中に囚われ迷って そうじゃないよと言い聞かせて 全てを自由に擦れるかなんて わからないよと空を霞んで 全てを自由に擦れるかなんて わからないよと空を霞んで A little pause... and we are back.
A little pause... and we are back.
A little pause...
and we are back.
A little pause... and we are back.
A little pause...
and we are back.
I will fight against fate.
I won't give up!
The stone I was tied to is not a struggle, but strength.
I will search for it.
The eyes I found will turn food into reality.
The world is for you.
It's the first time.
The memories I held in my heart will continue from that day on.
I can fly.
Brain-2!
Brain-3!
Brain-4 and Brain-3 make a thousand lives.
Can't you give up?!
This is the next organisation.
A little pause... and we are back.